ça avance très bien aujourd'hui je fais
de la langue espagnole anglais
la première épreuve officielle du bac
n'est que dans deux semaines mais paul
est déjà convoqué pour son oral de
langue mercredi saint john aujourd'hui
au programme c'est d'une dernière
relecture et peaufinage de son accent un
pc à dos pour le respect des couleurs
extrêmes et à l'as un masque et ses
cartes avant la séance
et scorait ce cd ce ban pas de cession
bibliothèque ni de rendez-vous du groupe
paul préfère travailler seules avec ou
sans musique mais toujours devant son
bureau face à ces notes il se concentre
du moins ils essayent son principal défi
c'est de maintenir son attention
c'est pas forcément super de travailler
chez soi parce que mon chat un
ordinateur qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qui empêche un peu de bien travailler
mais sinon j arrive à peu près à
m'organiser
ce jeune garçon semble plutôt serein
toute l'année il s'est imposé un rythme
de travail une cadence qui s'accélère
depuis quelques semaines deux heures de
révisions avant le dîner désert après je
pense qu'on en fait un peu tout un monde
de ce bac alors qu'en soi c'est il
suffit de relativement bien travaillé
toute l'année et on on réussit assez
bien
mais le secret de paul c'est de
s'octroyer de vrais moments de détente
pause télé et surtout bon goûter un
esprit sain dans un corps sain tout ce
qu'il faut pour être en forme le fameux
jour j